Yellowstone National Park is one of the must-see
locations in the U.S., but underneath it is
one of about 20 supervolcanoes around the
world and it could erupt at any time.
Ahhh nature.
A supervolcano is one that ejects more than
1,000 cubic kilometers of pumice and ash in
a single eruption.
The result of a super-eruption would be soot
in the atmosphere blocking sunlight and cooling
the planet for years, changing the global
climate enough to kill a significant number
of species.
(Possibly including us…)
This, is scarier than a comet or asteroid
impact because we can’t send Bruce Willis
to blow it up.
It’s right in our backyard.
So, naturally NASA has come up with a way
to delay that devastating event and generate
clean energy in the process.
Seismologists believe the supervolcano under
Yellowstone erupts once every 600,000 or so
years.
The odds we’ll see it are low, but we’re
coming up on that thermal breaking point where
it will blow… eventually.
NASA’s plan is to cool the magma chambers
inside the supervolcano so it doesn’t.
Most of Yellowstone’s heat — between 60
and 70 percent — is lost through leaking,
via hot springs.
Experts say that cutting 35-percent of the
remaining heat could stop this super-volcano
from erupting!
Volcanic heat is already used by people in
Iceland to heat and power their homes.
We do everything bigger in America… so let’s
tap into the biggest volcano that we have!
NASA’s plan is to drill as far as 10 kilometres
down inside the Yellowstone Caldera and pump
in high-pressure water to absorb the heat.
Coming out of the volcano, that scorching
water would be used to power a geothermal
energy plant.
There are a couple ways to do this…
The super hot water could be brought to a
cooling tank, and as it cools, it would turn
into water vapour, a process called flash
vaporization.
16c.That vapor could then drive a turbine
that powers a generator, providing energy.
Another option is a binary cycle power plant
that uses something called a heat transfer
fluid.
The fluid turns into vapor as the superheated
water passes through a heat transfer tank.
But, again, it’s the vapor that powers the
turbine to power the generator.
In either case, there are lots of benefits
to geothermal power, which could provide energy
to the surrounding area for as much as 10,000
years!
It’s clean, available around the clock,
has low emissions, and a small footprint,
and because of that, a minimal environmental
impact.
The problem with this crazy planet-saving,
energy-yielding NASA plan is that: it’s
not perfect.
A misplaced drill could trigger a supereruption,
and the 3.46 billion dollar price tag is pretty
much a non-starter.
But the eruption will happen if we don’t
do something.
It’s inevitable.
And though 3.46 billion dollars sounds like
a lot -- the U.S.
Government spends that about every eight hours.
And this might be worth saving the planet,
and if nothing else when NASA releases the
details, this could get researchers thinking
about other solutions to this bubbling time
bomb.
Yellowstone National Park is amazing.
And if you visit, you might want to make a
website of pictures to share.
Which means you need a domain from Domain
dot com.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
Get 20% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
This solution might sound crazy, but it really
isn’t.
We looked at a plan to capture and store carbon
dioxide in the oceans in this episode right
here.
Which plan do you guys think is more exciting?
Let us know in the comments, be sure to like
this video, and subscribe for more Seeker.